Transcription: Guillaume Rouy
Relecteur: eric vautier
Quand j’étais petite, l’écologie,
c’était un combat pour le monde d’après.
On parlait des générations futures.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un combat
qui se vit au présent.
Le printemps est devenu silencieux.
Les émissions de CO2 n'ont jamais été
aussi élevées qu'aujourd'hui.
Et si on continue à ce rythme-là,
on aura explosé notre budget carbone
en six années.
Alors face à ce constat, je me suis
d'abord sentie toute petite, impuissante,
écrasée par l’éco-anxiété.
Il y en a qui font
des dépressions amoureuses.
Moi, c’est la dépression climatique
qui m’a soufflée.
En fait, c’est simple,
ma vie est devenue un bilan carbone.
Je pouvais ordonner les grammes de CO2
par passager kilomètre
de tous les modes de transport,
hésiter trois heures
au rayon fruits et légumes,
entre une tomate bio française
élevée sous serre chauffée
et une tomate marocaine
rapportée en cargo,
et compter les grammes de CO2 ingérés
comme on compte les calories.
Un morceau de poulet ? 50 grammes de CO2.
À ce stade, j’ai compris que si je voulais
continuer à avoir des amis,
un semblant de vie sociale,
il fallait que je change d’angle,
que j’essaie de trouver des solutions.
Alors, j’ai commencé à éplucher
tous les scénarios, rapports, études,
qui dépeignaient des futurs possibles.
Et parmi tous ces scénarios, j’ai
découvert le miracle de la technologie.
La technologie,
ça avait l’air d’être un truc incroyable.
À chaque fois qu’il y a un problème,
il suffit d’inventer une technologie
pour le résoudre.
Trop de CO2 dans les villes ?
Pas de problème, on va inventer des villes
connectées pour gérer nos déchets
et nos émissions.
Trop de CO2 dans l’air ?
Aucun problème.
On peut inventer des aspirateurs géants
de CO2 pour le stocker dans le sol.
Et puis, si la biodiversité s’effondre,
ce n’est pas grave, on aura
des animaux virtuels dans le métavers.
Plus j’ai creusé, et plus j’ai pris
conscience que la technologie
apparaissait comme la solution magique
pour sauver l’humanité.
Et à un moment, moi aussi,
j’ai eu envie d’y croire.
Croire qu’il suffisait de mettre
la technologie dans les bonnes mains
pour trouver les bonnes solutions.
Mais j’en suis revenue.
Et ce soir, j’ai envie de discuter
avec vous de ce qu’il y a de problématique
dans ce fétichisme
du techno-solutionnisme.
Tout d'abord, la technologie
a toujours un impact.
Elle consomme des ressources, de l'eau,
des métaux, de l'énergie.
Par exemple, le secteur du numérique
représente 4% des émissions mondiales.
Mais surtout, il croît
à un rythme de 8% par an.
Ça veut dire qu'il aura doublé d'ici 2025.
Un ordinateur de 2 kg requiert 22 kg
de produits chimiques pour être produit,
240 kg de combustible et 1,5 tonne d’eau.
Le cloud qu’on s’imagine flottant
comme un nuage,
arriverait presque à nous faire oublier
la matérialité de ce monde
pseudo-immatériel.
La tête dans les nuages
pour oublier qu’on a la tête sous l’eau.
Parce que 99% des données
numériques mondiales
transitent par des câbles
sous-marins géants
pour être ensuite stockés
dans des monstres de métal :
les data centers.
Alors, ce secteur fait tout
sauf dématérialiser nos vies.
Mais par une stratégie de rapt sémantique,
il tente de poétiser
la destruction méthodique du vivant.
Et là vous allez me dire : « Oui,
la technologie a un impact,
mais si elle permet au global
de réduire nos émissions,
est-ce que ce n’est pas
un mal pour un bien ? »
Ça, c’était sans compter une deuxième
mauvaise nouvelle : l’effet rebond.
Concrètement, l’effet rebond,
ça veut dire qu’à chaque fois
qu’on invente une technologie
pour améliorer l’usage d’une ressource,
dans le même temps,
on va intensifier son usage
et donc on va effacer
le gain énergétique potentiel.
L’exemple de l’aviation
en est un exemple parfait.
Depuis les années 90, on a divisé par deux
l’intensité par passager
kilomètre d’un avion.
Mais dans le même temps,
on a multiplié par 4,6 le volume du trafic
et donc on a multiplié par plus de deux
les émissions absolues.
Donc on consomme moins par unité,
mais on consomme toujours plus d’unités.
Et ce raisonnement, il est valable
pour l'intégralité des secteurs.
Je m’achète une voiture plus efficace ?
J’en profite pour rouler
plus longtemps, plus loin.
Je m’achète un ordinateur reconditionné ?
Je me permets de m’en acheter un deuxième,
puisqu’il est reconditionné, etc.
Mais en plus de ça,
ces améliorations technologiques,
elles vont permettre des nouveaux usages
qui étaient impossibles sans elles.
Prenons cette fois l'exemple de la 5G.
Pour un volume de données équivalent,
la 5G est dix fois plus efficace
énergétiquement que la 4G.
Sauf que dans le même temps, elle entraîne
une explosion des données transférées.
Donc ça, c'est l'effet rebond.
Et en parallèle,
elle va ouvrir la boîte de Pandore
des objets connectés, du métavers,
de plein d’usages qui étaient
impossibles sans elle
et qui vont eux-mêmes requérir
de nouvelles ressources pour fonctionner.
Donc, quand on a commencé
à parler de la 5G,
on nous a vendu des usages incroyables
dans la médecine, les smart grids.
Ce qu’on constate aujourd’hui
dans les pays où elle est développée,
c’est surtout une explosion des vidéos
de chats et de Candy Crush,
voire des vidéos de chats jouant à Candy
Crush, générées par ces mêmes outils.
La boucle est bouclée.
Là, vous allez me dire « OK, mais si
on inventait une énergie 100% décarbonée,
est-ce que ce ne serait pas ça,
la solution ? »
La réponse est non.
Et ce serait même le pire des scénarios,
comme le dit l’astrophysicien
et philosophe Aurélien Barrau.
Parce qu’on n’aura pas résolu le problème
tant qu’il sera économiquement viable
et socialement valorisé de transformer
des forêts primaires en dalles de béton.
Parce que le techno-solutionnisme,
c’est la solution à un problème mal posé.
Le vrai problème, c'est la vie qui meurt.
Notre attitude prédatrice
envers le vivant.
Il faut qu’on arrête de traiter
uniquement les symptômes
pour se rendre compte que c’est le cœur
de notre modèle qui est malade.
Parce que penser qu’on peut résoudre
la crise climatique
en réduisant ses émissions
grâce à la technologie,
c’est un peu comme essayer
de soigner sa varicelle
en mettant du fond
de teint sur ses boutons.
La vraie question bien posée,
c’est celle non pas des externalités,
mais des finalités.
C’est celle de savoir dans quel monde
nous souhaitons vivre.
Alors, il ne s’agit pas
de revenir à la bougie,
mais plutôt de se poser la question :
« À quelles conditions est-ce
que la technologie peut être utile ? »
Et moi, je pense qu’elle peut l’être,
à condition d’être techno-lucide,
C’est-à-dire de penser les fins
avant les moyens.
Penser les fins, ça veut dire qu'il faut
sortir de l'innovation pour l'innovation,
sortir d’un usage boulimique
de la technologie
pour mettre des ressources limitées
au service de besoins raisonnés.
Et ça, c’est une question
éminemment politique,
parce que ça veut dire qu’il faut
qu’on décide collectivement
de ce qui est de l’ordre du superflu
et de ce qui nous permettra
non pas de survivre, mais de bien vivre.
Et on peut par exemple considérer que
ne pas tous disposer de tongs connectées,
ce n’est pas forcément une contrainte,
c’est même un progrès.
Cette question de la finalité,
c’est une question
qu’on se pose au quotidien
avec l’association
que je copréside : Data For Good.
Data For Good,
c’est né du constat que les cerveaux
les plus brillants de ma génération
passaient plus de temps
à faire cliquer des gens sur des pubs
qu’à essayer de résoudre
les grands défis du siècle.
Alors on a constitué une armée
de 4000 bénévoles experts de la tech,
qui donnent de leur temps pour
accompagner des projets d’intérêt général
avec comme arme du code open source
et l’envie d’agir un octet à la fois.
Par exemple, en utilisant les données
pour lutter contre les pratiques
de pêche frauduleuses avec l’ONG Bloom.
Concrètement, ça veut dire
qu’on traque des bateaux pour savoir
quand ils pêchent sans en avoir le droit,
ou alors quand ils disent
qu’ils ne pêchent pas
alors qu’ils sont très clairement
en train de le faire.
Jusqu’à aujourd’hui, Bloom a déposé
trois plaintes manuelles
en allant chercher
toutes les informations à la main.
Avec Data for Good, nous automatisons et
industrialisons la remontée d’informations
pour permettre de lutter contre la fraude
sur plus de 2000 bateaux.
Une fois qu’on a pensé ses fins,
on peut commencer à penser les moyens.
Et ces moyens,
ils doivent être pensés
pour limiter et minimiser au maximum
l’usage des ressources sur l’intégralité
du cycle de vie des produits
et pour remplacer les solutions
les plus polluantes.
Concrètement, ça veut dire
qu’il va falloir accepter
qu’il y ait des projets
qu’on ne fera tout simplement pas
et d’autres qu’il faudra arrêter plutôt
que de placer des patchs technologiques.
Chez Data for Good, ça veut dire
qu’on refuse tous les projets de capteurs
ou d’écoconception de logiciels
qui vendent des produits
dont on n’a tout simplement pas besoin.
Mais par contre, on accompagne des ONG
qui font un usage sobre des ressources
pour l'intérêt général.
Par exemple, l’ONG Pyronear qui aide les
pompiers à lutter contre les incendies.
Concrètement, ils ont pensé un petit
dispositif assez sobre énergétiquement.
C’est un micro-ordinateur
et une micro-caméra embarquée
qui sont disposés sur une tour de guet
et qui vont permettre, en temps réel,
grâce à un algorithme
open source de deep learning,
de traiter les images
et de détecter les départs de feu
pour prévenir les pompiers.
Aujourd’hui, ce dispositif,
il est présent dans sept zones en France,
principalement en Ardèche et en Gironde.
Il permet de surveiller
250 000 hectares de forêt,
soit 350 000 terrains de foot.
Et pas plus tard
qu’il y a quelques semaines,
il a permis de détecter un incendie
à plus de quinze kilomètres
de la tour de guet.
Enfin, pour être utile,
la technologie doit être pensée
pour rendre les hommes
et les femmes autonomes par design.
Ivan Illich, penseur de l’écologie
politique, définit les outils conviviaux
comme répondant à trois exigences.
Ils doivent augmenter l’efficacité
sans réduire l’autonomie,
ne générer ni esclave ni maître,
et augmenter le rayon
d’action personnelle.
Les réseaux sociaux sont des exemples
d'outils non conviviaux.
Ils sont pensés pour capter
notre attention et nous rendre dépendants.
À l’inverse, un outil
qu’on a voulu convivial
avec Data for Good
et l’association Open Food Facts,
c’est l’éco-score,
pour permettre aux citoyens
de comprendre l’empreinte carbone
de leur alimentation.
Parce qu’on est convaincu
que comprendre que, par exemple,
1 kg de bœuf génère 30 kg de CO2
contre 900 grammes
pour 1 kg de pois chiches,
ça peut permettre de faire
des choix de consommation éclairés.
Alors sur mon chemin,
j’ai découvert que non,
la technologie n’allait pas nous sauver.
Mais j'ai aussi découvert
que c'était une chance.
Une chance d’inventer
un nouveau rapport au monde,
de redéfinir le confort, le succès,
l’important.
Une chance de sortir
d’une vision étriquée de nos vies
où tout est optimisation.
Une chance de découvrir la force
du collectif et des liens vivants.
Une chance de vivre tout court.
Sur mon chemin, j’ai également appris
que je pouvais être non pas éco-anxieuse,
mais éco-furieuse,
grâce à Frédéric Lordon.
Être éco-furieuse,
ça veut dire canaliser ses peurs
vers des actions concrètes et collectives
de transformation radicale des systèmes.
C’est sortir d’un rapport individuel,
psychologique de la crise écologique
pour passer à un rapport politique
de transformation du réel.
Être éco-furieuse, c’est comprendre
que je ne suis pas complètement folle,
mais lucide dans un monde devenu fou.
Alors soyons lucides
pour rester vivants.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)